we always we could be part of one of our
favorite video games some of them are
too dangerous for that but running
everywhere and collecting money seems to
be good for our health and our wallet
and instead of traveling to the virtual
world our favorite characters are now
part of our universe you'll have to
watch until the end to see what Sonic
the Hedgehog looks like love watching
our videos but looking for a more
ad-free browsing experience take your
video view into the next level and sign
up for the premium network you'll get
the first peek at the newest content
from not only the riches but Screen Rant
the taco the sports dearth of things and
many more thousands of your favorite
videos in one place is a no-brainer
click here to be the first in line for
the premium if you love videogames and
cosplay as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 sonic characters in real life Amy
Rose she is every girl's favorite this
cheerful character is full of energy and
also really pretty but just like any
other woman she is not perfect she has a
scary temper and can become really
obsessed sometimes you might not know
that she used to be called Rosie the
rascal but if there is one thing that
everyone noticed about her it is that
she has a huge crush on Sonic we can't
blame her he is probably the
best-looking Hedgehog we know and
actually one of the only hedgehogs we
know she met him on little planet and
since that day she follows him
everywhere and claims that she is his
girlfriend but Sonic doesn't seem to be
really into it because she keeps doing
things to win his heart and just like
any other girl obsessed by her crush we
know that nothing will stop her from
getting what she wants the Hedgehog
doesn't mind too much about it
so there is nothing wrong with that we
all like that kind of a tense
sometimes cosplayer Yami Ross created
the perfect costume to portray Amy Rose
she has the same dress and used makeup
to turn herself into an animal we also
love to see that she made a Piko Piko
Hammer as we know that Amy never leaves
home without it we just hope that Yami
Ross won't meet Sonic at a cosplay event
if this happens
she will spend the day following that
guy everywhere Knuckles the Echidna if
you are looking for a strong and
independent character knuckles is the
one you should choose he is the only
remaining descendant of the knuckles
clan and also the last it's HIPPA on
earth in real life these creatures still
exist but if there is one thing special
about it it is that it is the only
living mammals that lay eggs they look
like a platypus mix with a hedgehog but
the achievement you see in the video
game is not like any other it has
superhuman strength and can climb walls
and dig in the ground with his spike
like knuckles this is where his name
comes from but don't worry even if he is
short tempered he probably won't use his
power against you he is devoted to his
mission which is being the guardian of
the Master Emerald a powerful ancient
relic he doesn't care about anything
else except saving his friends when they
are in trouble another animal was
inspired by this hero and decided to
dress up just like him this time it is
not a human cause playing his favorite
character but a little hedgehog its
spikes are now red and it is also
wearing shoes just like the video game
character if this animal has one
superpower it is probably being
extremely cute it might not look
dangerous but no one could say no if it
told us not to approach the Master
Emerald
miles tails Prower here's the character
that everyone loves miles-per-hour
better known as tails but it hasn't
always been like this when we first met
him he was very timid and not
courageous as a fox born with two tails
many people made fun of him and this is
why he became less confident but
everything changed when he met Sonic he
thought that he was so cool that he
wanted to be just like him and this is
why tails started following Sonic on all
of his crazy adventures his new hero
inspired him to become more outgoing
brave and independent he turned his
Difference into something positive by
rotating his tails like a helicopter to
fly we bet that no one will bully him
now that they see all the incredible
things he can do and this is how he
became a hero in his own right he is not
only Sonic's best friend but also his
sidekick what a better way to cosplay
this character than with his friends the
Hedgehog two sisters who go by the name
of opposite cosplay decided to dress up
as their favorite characters Katy and
Nicole bear loved video games and they
couldn't find a better duo their costume
suits them perfectly and we can see
their personality shine through the only
thing that we don't understand is how
they could walk on the grass with those
heels if they are able to do that we
think that they are even more powerful
than the video game characters Metal
Sonic this is a character that we love
to hate the perfect mix of Sonic and dr.
Eggman the antagonist deadliest creation
was created to destroy the Hedgehog and
we have to admit that we were scared
when we first saw him he doesn't only
look like our hero but it can also make
the same moves and run faster than him
how can sonic fight with another
character who has the same powers and
barely any flaw it is a really
intelligent machine with a cold heart
and it is obsessed with trying to prove
that it is superior to Sonic when we
think about it Metal Sonic probably
represents everything dr. Eggman would
like to be the reason why he cares so
much about the Hedgehog is probably that
he is jealous of him no matter what we
were able to defeat him when playing the
video games Metal Sonic would always
come back in
times but this was never enough to stop
us and no one will be able to stop this
cosplayer from creating the best Metal
Sonic costume we have ever seen and
listo created this amazing costume for
the O Catan in 2011 and he said that he
has never been so popular in his entire
life but it is funny to think that his
goal was actually to look like mecha
sonic and not Metal Sonic anyway it is
an awesome costume no matter which
character he is cosplay cream the rabbit
now let's take a look at a character who
wouldn't hurt anyone
cream is really well-mannered and pure
some people might call her naive and
childish but we think that seeing the
world this way is what makes her happier
cream always lived a beautiful and
idyllic life with her family until dr.
Eggman tried to make that change but she
was saved by Sonic and his friends and
quickly decided to join them on their
adventures she might look like a sweet
girl but don't underestimate her cream
is one of the youngest characters but
she always tries her best and stands up
for herself her friends are really
important to her and this is why she is
always there to help them she makes a
great sidekick for Amy Rose but did you
know that she was first supposed to be a
fox like tails they also tried to design
her as a squirrel with many tails but
we're happy that they finally chose the
rabbit and what if she was a human just
look at how the cosplayer Araya Skye
reimagined her she is cuter than what we
would have imagined
instead of bunny ears she has long hair
that she wears in pigtails and no matter
in which world she is Amy Rose is always
by her side would you like to be her
friend in real life we think that cream
would be the perfect
BFF dr. Eggman here is the man we
usually don't want to see but today we
are too curious to know what it would
look like in real life so we will give
him a chance did you know that his real
name is dr. Ivo Robotnik this is
probably inspired by his love for robots
as we have seen it before the mad
scientist claims that he has an IQ of
300 and wants to dominate the world but
we know that if you were really that
smart he would understand that being
good is the best solution anyway he
doesn't seem to be interested in helping
others when he turns animals into robots
to create his army his goal is to create
the Eggman Empire and now he also wants
to conquer the whole universe but you
don't have to worry Sonic and his
friends always make his plans fail or
will he have a better chance in the real
world after all surrounded by so many
humans he can have a lot of allies but
when we look at him we know that this is
a man we wouldn't trust cosplayer velu
Vector dressed up as dr. Eggman and we
think that the results were really
realistic we didn't think that anyone
could have such a big moustache but he
managed to find a way to make it come to
life velu really enjoys his Eggman
costume and we have to admit that it is
a character that we love to hate Shadow
the Hedgehog you have probably seen this
character before but do you know his
story shadow was created by Gerald
Robotnik as the ultimate life-form the
scientist was trying to develop cures
for incurable diseases by using the DNA
of black doom and a hedgehog in the
project shadow unfortunately he didn't
get the results that he expected people
thought that the creature was a threat
to humanity so he was captured but years
later
Eggman released him and tried to use it
as a weapon to destroy the earth
but Shadow the Hedgehog finally
remembered the past and he turned out to
be the one who saved the world now we
know him as a character who is ready to
do anything to accomplish his goals he
has the same skills and speed as Sonic
but one thing that makes them really
different is that Shadow prefers to work
alone but no matter what he will always
be the
when his friends need help we wish that
we could be independent like him
sometimes and it looks like cosplayer
molecular Agatha was inspired by this
character when we see her attitude she
looks like a strong and independent
woman who doesn't need anyone to be
happy she's the one who made the design
and the costume for a convention cause
party in 2014 in Costa Rica and as we
can see she didn't need the help of
anyone else to look incredible
Charmy be look at which character flew
by it's charming be the bee might not be
the most popular character in the video
game but we think that he deserves a lot
of attention this character is full of
energy and is sometimes too hyperactive
he can get on our nerves when he is loud
not too smart and a little immature but
that's totally normal as he is a child
when we were young we would rather play
than work just like him and no matter
what we love him because he has a big
heart and he is very friendly and we
certainly need someone like him
Charmy is the co-founder of the chaotix
detective agency we are really happy to
know that he is part of our team when we
see what he can do with his tracking
skills he might not be as good as SPO in
Factor because of his very young age but
we are pretty sure that when he grows up
he will be one of the best detectives
that ever existed and it seems like he
had time to grow up while he was
traveling to our world
look at this grown up cosplayer dressed
as Charmy beef what do you think
mink the artist is looking for in the
flowers we bet that he is soon going to
be using his tracking skills to find
something interesting in there
rogue the bat we know that she is coming
as we have already heard the sound of
her high heels on the floor as we won't
be disappointed when we see that she is
a very beautiful lady but don't let her
seduce you too quickly she is actually a
jewelry thief rogue is a famous treasure
hunter and she is also known to work as
a part-time spy for the government
you'll also learn really quickly that
she has a weakness for jewels and what
the things she is looking for is the
Master Emerald
knuckles won't be happy to hear that
robe the bat it's the kind of woman who
knows what she wants she is an enigma as
no one can truly understand what she
really would it helps a lot to be smart
sassy and seductive who could blame her
for acting this way we would probably
take advantage of the situation if we
looked like her
however we wouldn't want to use this
power to steal jewels but to save the
world just like rogue did when she
helped Sonic and his friends just like
the character cosplayer Mimi legend is
really pretty she has a fierce attitude
and she seems to be ready to take over
the world but this time we think that
the only thing she is going to steal is
our heart
Sonic the Hedgehog we have been waiting
for him during all this time and he is
finally here he is sorry for being late
he was on the other side of the world at
the beginning of the video and he just
ran here to say hi the famous video game
character has the ability to run faster
than the speed of sound this is what
inspired his name and he won't use his
power to run after girls or escape the
cops Sonic wants to fight injustice and
help people in need
he already restored peace in the world
many times and he is always ready for
another battle Sonic might be the
strongest and fastest Hedgehog we know
but he would be nothing without his
friends they're always by his side to
help him throughout his adventures all
around the world once again little
hedgehogs decided to dress up as their
favorite superheroes their spikes are
now blue and they are also wearing tiny
red shoes we would love to give them a
lot of kisses but we are afraid that we
would get hurt so we will just stay a
little farther and admire them because
they are too cute is there any sonic
character that you would like to see in
real life make sure to tell us who it is
in the comment section down below and
give us a thumbs up if your favourite
character is already part of our list
and that's it for 10 sonic characters in
like for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 paw patrol dogs in
real life thanks for watching
[Music]